hello my name is Yan Pushkov my talk is
called cloud notebooks where I'll give a
general introduction to how notebooks
work in the Wolfram cloud talk about
some new and upcoming features and share
some insights what to keep in mind when
deploying content to the Wolfram cloud
and lead developer on the cloud
notebooks team and our mission is to
make notebook interfaces work on the web
and especially in the Wolfram cloud most
of you are probably familiar with
Mathematica notebooks but just to give
you a brief introduction is this big
enough or should I okay give you a quick
introduction the idea of notebooks is of
course to have computable documents
where you can mix regular text like this
section section cell here with math and
code and interactive content so you know
I can do things like typing and you text
cell here
and I can do evaluations like entering a
new computation and I get back a result
after pressing shift enter of course
there are things like more sophisticated
math that might produce some more
complex output like this one there is 2d
graphics like this plot also 3d graphics
that
are sort of interactive and I drag this
with a mouse I can I can rotate this I
can also resize graphics of course and
and things like that the sort of
interactive part is that you can even
create new interactive user interfaces
in notebooks in a simple case like this
you just create a button and when you
click it
it's low it produces a new cell in the
notebook that just printed something
it's a very simple case a very powerful
function in Mathematica interval from
language is manipulate where you have
some expression like this plot here that
depends on parameters like a and B here
and it just magically produces this user
interface where you can drag sliders to
change the parameters and the content
will update accordingly so that's how
notebooks work in general
and this is what we make work in web
browsers which by the way I'm running
here so this is not test of Mathematica
now this is my web browser connected to
the Wolfram cloud and it just happened
to have a notebook here that since loud
in slideshow mode that's why it looks a
bit different so there's you know just
to emphasize this there's it doesn't
rely on any local installation of
Mathematica or any plugin it's just the
browser rendering stuff on the client
side and then for evaluations when it
needs the kernel it makes requests to
the server we're in our Wolfram cloud
there there from engines running to to
make the such computations so that's
that's the final goal to make these
notebook interfaces work there most of
the stuff that I showed you here isn't
really new I think that was already
working about a year ago but we've been
really focusing on over the last year is
sort of improvements under the hood and
optimizations mostly so we've made
various performance optimizations in our
JavaScript codes that renders notebooks
so one metric I had was that I think if
you have a large notebook the initial
rendering got about twice as fast over
the over the last year we've made
improvements particularly to graphics so
that especially updates of graphics or
faster
let's see when you have a manipulate and
you drag a slider and it changes some
parts of a plot well most of the other
things stay the same that's much faster
now thanks to our use of react
JavaScript library that takes care of
updating the browser content and apart
from performance we also focused on the
download size of the JavaScript and also
CSS bundles that are needed to render
notebooks in the browser so we've made
some progress on that already but it's
it's still you know still an ongoing
process of optimizing that even further
not so much reducing the overall size of
our code because that will probably
always grow if as we add more features
but we try to be more clever about what
we really know to really need to load
initially to you know give you to render
the notebook initially and then as you
need more of the code we load that
lazily using webpack and then code
splitting and that already leads into
one really useful improvement that we
made over the last year I think is that
we we can now really render notebooks on
the server side quite well and the idea
is that we produce some static piece of
HTML that doesn't really rely on
JavaScript anymore and we can send that
to the browser right away when you
request a notebook page so that you see
something immediately or almost
immediately while we download all the
necessary JavaScript code in the
background and that eventually makes the
notebook interactive but at least to see
something we get there much quicker so
it feels more like a regular web page in
the end in terms of in terms of speed
the way this works is that whenever you
edit a notebook and then also close it
in the cloud we generates this this
static piece of HTML and also when you
upload
notebook you know either through the
upload button in the cloud or through
functions like cloud deploy from desktop
Mathematica whenever something like that
happens we generate a static HTML cache
for the notebook and then use it anytime
the notebook is visited it doesn't
happen synchronously and it takes a
little bit so if you deploy a notebook
and then visit it right away the cache
might not be there yet but if you wait a
few seconds it you know any subsequent
visit should should perform much better
the way we're doing this now has has
changed over time we've been relying on
browser rendering in the very beginning
where we would send the HTML cache from
the browser that was actually editing a
notebook to the server then we switch to
selenium running on the server but that
has it had its problem as well so now
we're using a node EGS process running
in a headless way on the server to to
render notebooks using the same
JavaScript code that you also use in the
browser yeah and that that works quite
well no I think it's not only good for
the performance of notebooks but also
for search engines because now that
there's some static piece of HTML right
on the page they can make much better
sense of the content of of notebooks and
so yeah it's good for search engines and
lastly but really trying to do here is
minimize any differences between the
static HTML that we render on the server
and what you might get eventually in in
the client-side when you render things
in a life way in the browser and one
important thing to do to make that
happen was to use the exactly same fonts
on the server and on the client because
you know that that static piece of HTML
uses you know relies on text measure
to know where things should go in a in a
completed form formula or so so it's
really important to have the same fonts
and if it you know used fonts that you
only had on your machine but we don't
have them on a server there would be
differences and what we're doing now is
basically only using web fonts in cloud
notebooks so that might be a little
surprising if you if you take a closer
look you might notice that where even if
you say a cell uses the font Arial or
something it's not actually using Arial
but just an open font that looks very
similar so you might notice little
differences but I think it it still
works well and the motivation is at
least part of the motivation is that we
have this very good consistency between
client and then server-side rendering
yep so that's that I only wanted to show
some new features that we developed
recently this one is not released on the
public cloud yet so I'm going to switch
to our test server where this is already
running this should be released in what
we call version 144 so probably in the
next week or soon after that so this is
a feature called multi click selection
it seems maybe on the surface like like
a small feature but if you're if you're
working with somewhat larger expressions
in your notebooks it's it's really very
useful and once you get used to it it
it's it's it's hard not having it
anymore so we really wanted to implement
this the idea is that you know you can
of course double click a symbol and it
will select the whole symbol but then
you can keep going and click and you'll
make a triple click just clicking very
fast in succession actually a small bug
here
and what it does then is it it extends
the selection in in a way where it's
aware of the structure so you know
instead of selecting the whole paragraph
at once which is what usual text editors
would do it just looks at the outer
expression and keeps extending it that
way so if a triple click I get that
whole thing and then if I keep going it
will you know to be fast enough it will
select something like this so especially
if you have large nested nested
expressions this is really useful to
figure out where they start and end
basically that being said there is still
some work to do so one thing that
doesn't work quite well yet is if you
have explicit new lines in your
expressions that something we still need
to fix and also it's not necessarily
aware of all the operator presidencies
so in in desktop Mathematica if you let
see something like this it would be
aware that the times operator it binds
you know stronger than the plus and and
the multi click selection would takes it
into account here it doesn't work that
perfectly yet so if a triple click this
it selects only this part when it should
really select the first part as well so
that's a minor thing we still need to
improve as well but at least in terms of
function calls and arguments it's it's
aware of that structure another sort of
user assist features feature is spell
checking also coming in 144 so if it's
not enabled by default for you you can
go to your user preferences and and
activate spell checking and then what
you should see is in this case where
it's not really English text anyway it
makes a lot of red underlines indicating
misspelled words you get suggestions how
to correct them or you could also ignore
individual instance
of misspellings again something that we
still need to do is have user-defined
dictionaries so that you can add words
to a dictionary and then that's you know
never flag this as misspelled it's
something we still need to implement and
of course it would be nice to share
dictionaries between your cloud account
and desktop Mathematica as well okay
that's some of the new features coming
soon and and these features are mostly
related to editing notebooks in the
cloud and so so in that sense cloud
notebooks are the primary interface to
what's going on in in your cloud account
and you can use them to deploy other
things like API functions and so on if
you don't have tests of Mathematica
especially but but cloud notebooks are
also the underlying technology for
notebooks deployed to the cloud that you
think can can share with other users
even if you don't edit them there and so
the question is how do you get your
content into the cloud the most
straightforward way is to just use cloud
deployed so if I have a some content
like this manipulate here I can just
call cloud deploy and it will put that
into the cloud in its one argument form
it will just produce an unnamed object
but most of the time if you want to
share things with other users you
probably want a nicer URL and then the
second argument is useful where you can
specify the path where it should go to
in your cloud account and also if you
want to share things important' to set
permissions there's a very powerful and
complex structure of possible
permissions in this case we're basically
saying that everyone even unauthentic
unauthenticated users should be able to
both read the notebook and also interact
with it and once we do that we get back
a cloud object and you can open this
link
and it will show me this this
manipulative course where I can now
interact with it and it just works as
expected I wanted to point out one thing
that claw deployed tries to be somewhat
smart about what object it produces and
you can tell if you know things like API
function and form function of course it
does something different depending on
what expression you give it and it also
does it to some extent with sort of
notebook content in this case it
produced an interactive notebook but if
you have a very static piece of content
like a grid and you deploy this one what
it produces still a cloud object of
course but it looks quite different
little bigger
too weak so you can see that it looks
very different from what we had here in
the notebook and the reason is that it
didn't actually produce a notebook
there's a little you know caveat here if
you look at the type of this static
object we can see that it's actually not
a notebook but it's this thing called
cloud CDF dot HTML which really means
that it produced a static piece of HTML
instead of just a notebook and sometimes
that's probably useful because you know
if you have some simple content you
might not want all the overhead that
comes with with interactive notebooks
necessarily but if you if you absolutely
want a notebook there is there still a
way to do that and by the way that that
HTML that it produced that's equivalent
to what you get by the HTML fragment
export format so you know what it
produced is basically this simple HTML
table and that we put that into a cloud
object and again if you
if you want an actual notebook there is
a way to do that you just need to be a
bit more explicit so instead of using
cloud deploy you can use cloud export
where you can specify the format that
should be produced and in this case we
say we want a notebook and then again we
just say where the cloud object should
be generated if I do this we get a cloud
object and this this is now a notebook
that looks much more similar to what we
had you know in our notebook in the
first place right so that's a little
thing to keep in mind when working with
cloud deploy also something that maybe
not explained very well in our
documentation yet but it's certainly
good to be aware of is the concept of
views in the cloud
we make a pretty fundamental distinction
between what we call the editor or
product view and the deployed view so
the editor view as the name suggests is
the the view where you edit your content
in the cloud usually so if you go to a
product like the developer platform or
mathematic online or so from one what
you see is is this edit of view where
usually you have a session kernel that's
tied to your browser session which means
that it's actually shared between
multiple notebooks if you have no
several cloud notebooks at the same time
if you have them open at the same time
in the same browser in the developer
platform for instance they actually
share a single kernel and if you you
know create a symbol in one notebook
that symbol will be available in the
other node as well pretty much like it
works on on desktop Mathematica by
default so that's your session kernel it
does expire after a certain time of
inactivity and then you just have to
refresh your session since it's tied to
products it's it does require a product
subscription usually for whatever
product you're using which also means
that it's requiring authentic
so anytime you want to go to product
view you have to to login doesn't
necessarily mean that you have to pay
for this because there's free
subscriptions to to most of the products
but at least you have to authenticate
and that's in contrast to the deployed
view which is what you get when you go
to www.irs.gov that notebook if you
visit that again was it just so-so here
can see the URL I can actually change
this on the fly so I can go to the
developer platform product view but just
changing this subdomain here and it's
still the same notebook same cloud
object but now I'm in a different view
where I could also edit this notebook
for instance so that's that's that
sometimes useful and yeah so it's just a
different view on the same notebook and
in a deployed view again it's it's we
are meant for public consumption so what
you get there is what we call a public
kernel it's the same thing that also API
functions use there's no real concept of
sessions or at least only short-lived
sessions and it also means that whatever
evaluations happen there they they
consume cloud credits of the owner of
the notebook since it's not using your
session call that you have anyway but
you know might have to spin up a lot of
kernels well we have to charge you some
some cloud credits for that again that's
made for public consumption so it does
not necessarily require authentication
it still depends on the permissions of
course so if if you have a private cloud
object it will of course not be visible
in the deployed view either
but what it means is that if you have a
public object like this one here it's to
unauthenticated users it's only visible
in the deployed view and they can't use
the product view of course so this is
the thing you want to use if you want to
share notebooks broadly or maybe embed
them on a website or something like that
just one little thing to point out in
terms of sessions
that's another improvement that we've
made recently which will be released a
little later this year we've made the
whole concept of notebook sessions a bit
more robust so what you won't see
anymore is this this error message that
says session timed out due to inactivity
and then you have to refresh the whole
page which was always a bit annoying so
instead what happens is that even if you
know the session terminates on the
server after some time we can just
resume it basically and you can keep
working on the notebook without
reloading the whole page that being said
the kernel session itself that still
expires after a while so and you will
still get a little notification about
that but it will it's much less
disruptive so if you know if the kernel
session expires you make another
evaluation it will just spin up a new
kernel on the fly you know finally some
some even longer term look out what
we're starting to work on now is a more
powerful box editor for math type
setting and also grids and things like
that on one hand and on the other hand
we're starting to work on live
collaboration on notebooks so that if
multiple users have write permission on
a notebook they can all edit it at the
same time there's still a lot of
questions to be answered about that but
but we're making some progress and
especially if you're interested in that
have some use cases for for either of
these
please let me know and we're out of time
now so thank you very much
[Applause]